on our last show before break we did a
bit with addison ray
where she taught me eight viral
tick-tock dances now we recognize that
the creators of those dances deserve to
have their own spotlight
jimmy fallon invites tick-tock creators
to perform their viral
hits following the addison ray
controversy
on monday's episode of the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon
the host virtually welcomed the creators
of five viral tick tock dances to
discuss their success
and perform their routines right now
some of the creators will join me to
talk about how their dance
went viral and then perform the dance
themselves their appearances came after
the late night host was criticized for
having addison ray perform the viral
dances on the show
without giving credit to the people who
created them
many of whom are black
[Music]
first up maya nicole johnson and chris
cotter who created the viral dance to
cardi b's hit
up
[Music]
yeah the dance is so viral even cardi
has noticed
that was really exciting she posted our
video two times on her instagram and
then one time on tick tock so yeah that
was a good experience
next up was young prince who created the
corvette corvette challenge
i want to be a all-around performer and
entertainer
will smith and kind of hard they're like
my inspirations i love their journey
then there was flyboy foo who created
the laffy taffy remix
and indy who choreographed the
accompanying dance
you're shocking because like i wouldn't
even expect it to go viral
dance creators mack daddy's came up with
the blinding lights challenge
[Music]
the flip move actually that was like our
go-to dance back then
so we put that in there we added some
hand movements
and it just kind of went together
perfectly and
last but certainly not least kiara
wilson who created the mega viral dance
to megan the stallion's track
savage i'm a savage classy
bougie it took me about 30 minutes to
choreograph because i kept changing the
ending
i never expected it to blow up like it
did i just did it for fun honestly
then i just kept seeing it grow
celebrities were doing it
little kids were doing it it was the
best
but i would have to say seeing my dance
bring joy to people throughout
quarantine was
definitely the best part in february et
spoke to kailyn castle
k-shell dabney and queen camira members
of the atlanta-based collab crib
i do understand that black creators are
trans status
for a lot of you know the content that
is being produced on tick tock but at
the same
time there's a way to involve yourself
in someone's culture without it becoming
cultural appropriation
they opened up about being black
creators on tick tock and
the cultural appropriation they've
witnessed on the platform
it's definitely really frustrating i
can't sit here and say it's not
sometimes it does mess with your mental
because you're like well dag like
because you're trying so hard and you're
doing exactly the same thing as other
people
you want people to appreciate us but at
the same time
it's a fun i think it's more in the
educational background where they
have to educate themselves before they
can
and like you know be involved
you